[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de
enlace conosur desde santiago de chile-
más de 15 millones de chilenos están
convocados a las urnas el próximo 4 de
septiembre con voto obligatorio por
primera vez desde 2012 y con muestras
que van hasta los 180 dólares los
chilenos deberán decidir si aprueban o
rechazan el texto constitucional
elaborado por 154 convencionales de
distintas opciones políticas pero de
mayoría izquierdista e independiente que
fue presentado el pasado 4 de julio se
trata de la primera constitución
elaborada por personas elegidas por el
pueblo en la historia de chile
acostumbrado en sus pocos más de dos
siglos de historia a constituciones
elaboradas por minorías y no validadas
por la ciudadanía es además el primer
texto constitucional elaborado de forma
paritaria en el mundo por cantidad igual
de hombres y mujeres que cuenta con
representación de minorías sexuales y
también con 17 escaños que fueron
reservados para los pueblos indígenas
[Música]
el texto destinado a reemplazar la
constitución de los militares de 1980
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet cuenta con 388 artículos y está
ahora chile como un estado democrático
de derecho plurinacional intercultural
regional y ecológico frente al estado
subsidiario consagrado en la
constitución de pinochet plantea una
democracia inclusiva establece la
paridad en todos los órganos del estado
y permite el aborto nos acercamos al
instituto de estudios avanzados de la
universidad de santiago la usach para
entrevistar a la analista política y
coordinadora de usach constituyente
pamela figueroa
te pasaríamos de una constitución que
está muy centrada en una visión más
neoliberal del rol del estado de cuáles
son los derechos sociales un estado más
unitario y con un presidencialismo
fuerte a una nueva constitución que
tendría derechos sociales un estado
social y democrático de derecho un
estado regional una democracia paritaria
y con mayor participación ciudadana así
que creo que son varios cambios que son
bien sustantivos porque en el fondo creo
que chile actualizaría sus instituciones
a una democracia que integraría a nuevos
grupos sociales que por ejemplo el tema
de la plurinacionalidad
los más controles si eso también es otro
punto que es muy relevante el nuevo
texto propone un estado plurinacional es
decir un reconocimiento constitucional
de los diez pueblos originarios de chile
más el pueblo afrodescendiente
que tendrían no solamente una
representación política al interior del
sistema político chileno sino que
también se considerarían derechos para
los pueblos indígenas un sistema de
justicia para los pueblos indígenas y
creo que eso también ha sido muy
relevante en las campañas por el apruebo
y por el rechazo llevan semanas
tomándose las calles en chile aunque las
encuestas dan como ganador al rechazo
desde antes incluso de que se concluyera
el texto constitucional la brecha entre
ambas opciones se ha reducido en las
últimas semanas pero la opción rechazo
sigue siendo ganadora según las últimas
encuestas publicadas 15 días antes del
plebiscito como marca la ley electoral
en chile en la prueba impulsado en su
campaña que se conozca el texto
constitucional que se ve empañado por el
proceso no exento de polémicas su parte
la propaganda del rechazo afirma que la
propuesta constitucional divide al país
y apuesta por construir un nuevo texto
desde el amor
mientras los chilenos han salido en más
acceso con el texto constitucional y la
constitución se ha convertido en el
libro más vendido de las librerías y
también en los comercios ambulantes pero
qué opina la gente en la calle está mal
hecha
porque no supieron hacerla por la gente
que cogieron no fuera indicar voy a
participar que le digo la constitución
yo voy a botar rechazos
porque esta zona constitución para
movilizar a un proyecto político y no
para establecer reglas del juego
político que de eso se trata de una
constitución porque contempla contempla
muchos derechos fundamentales que no
fueron contemplados la constitución del
80 cambia también el carácter del estado
que ya no va a ser un estado subsidiario
sino un estado que se va a hacer cargo
efectivamente de las personas hay una
tutela de derecho mucho más amplia como
el derecho a la vivienda el derecho a la
educación el derecho a la salud que es
la constitución del 80 solamente estaban
mencionadas más sino protegidos más y no
garantizados entonces siento que la
constitución la propuesta constitucional
nos dan un amplio catálogo derecho que
antes no estaba sigan en la prueba el
proyecto será promulgado por el gobierno
de gabriel boric favorable a esta opción
su gobierno deberá enviar al congreso
alrededor de un centenar de proyectos
para llevar a la práctica los artículos
si se impone el rechazo seguirá vigente
la constitución legada por los militares
aunque el presidente boris afirmó que si
este es el caso se iniciará un nuevo
proceso constituyente para elegir otros
convencionales y escribir un nuevo texto
se iniciaría así de nuevo todo el
proceso que fue impulsado como una
salida democrática a las masivas
manifestaciones y violento estallido
social de octubre de 2019 que demandaban
mejores pensiones salud y educación
menos desigualdad y más dignidad para
todos los chilenos
el nuevo proceso constitucional debería
ser trazado no obstante fue el actual
congreso uno de los más fragmentados en
la historia de la democracia en el país
que pasará en las urnas una de las
mayores incógnitas es cuántas personas
van a participar con voto obligatorio y
si esto puede favorecer a una u otra
opción será esta plaza el punto
neurálgico de las manifestaciones de
octubre de 2019 el lugar de celebración
y si es así quieren celebrar a los
partidarios de la prueba o los del
rechazo de lo que ocurre el próximo 4 de
septiembre les estaremos informando aquí
en nuevas ediciones de enlace conosur